pain and suffering and sorrow
are my key emotions right now yeah um
this has
ripped ripped my family to pieces she's
been left to drown
left to drown
12 days before her 12th birthday um and
she hasn't made it home i've sent her
out to go to a party to a place where
kids go and enjoy their self and she
hasn't been protected she hasn't been
safeguarded she hasn't
she hasn't been looked after you know
um yeah i feel really i feel really
really let down i'm set i'm so sad that
she's gone because me and her of
me and i have a unbreakable bond we have
an unbreakable bond where we're we're
we're we're that tight we're that time
and
they've ripped they've ripped
one of my closest
people to me in life away from me
because
they haven't acted in urgency i could
okay okay i could i could say so much
she was funny she was funny she was
making jokes always making jokes um but
yeah she was
she was one of my besties mate she was
one of my besties yeah she was one of my
besties and
yeah
i just miss her like she this her energy
losing her is like a
massive energy loss
i don't want any other parent to go
through this again
it's unfair
it's unfair
like what i'm going through right now
what i'm going through right now what
what our family's going through right
now
it's disturbing
it's disturbing to relive
to relive
seeing
my child's dead body
yeah her eyes rolled back
because she's died at a water park
because she's died at a water park and
she could have been saved
well skye's iva bennett joins us from
liquid leisure
in windsor desperately sad hearing from
kyra hill's father there iva where are
we with this case so far
yeah as you can imagine cairo's family
were absolutely devastated by what
happened she came here to celebrate one
of her best friend's birthday's parties
but she never made it home and as you
heard there her father leonard
told me that her death has ripped the
family to pieces she's left behind a
younger brother age three who apparently
asks about her every single day and an
older sister a 14 year old sister who is
apparently
her best friend now as he heard there
leonard her father is firmly of the
belief that her death could have been
prevented accusing the water park liquid
leisure is the company
of neglect
and accusing them of leaving her
daughter to his daughter to drown the
incident happened on august the 6th just
over two weeks ago she was swimming in a
an area of the lake that's designated
for swimming she wasn't wearing a life
jacket but it's not required in that
section it is required in another
section of the lake where there's a
floating obstacle course but as i say
she wasn't in that area she was in the
designated swimming area she got into
difficulty and and leonard says that she
wasn't found for nearly two hours later
he says that there was only one
lifeguard on duty in that
area of the lake he says staff were slow
to respond taking more than 30 minutes
to call the emergency services
and he accuses them of searching in the
wrong area in the rest of the lake and
and in the car park but he claims he she
was actually found in the same area of
water this small sectioned off area of
the lake where she had gone missing
initially where she had been swimming
and she was taken to hospital nearby
wexen park hospital where she was
pronounced dead that afternoon now we've
put these claims to the company liquid
leisure and had a response
they say in a statement
everyone at liquid leisure is
heartbroken by the tragic incident on
august 6th and our thoughts remain with
the family and all those affected we
have been working closely with the
various authorities to assist the
ongoing investigation as a result we are
limited in what we can say about the
incident itself at this stage
we can confirm that the incident took
place in the designated swimming area of
our lake which always has a fully
trained royal life-saving society
lifeguard on duty
liquid leisure windsor has been
operating for over 20 years and has
welcomed hundreds of thousands of
visitors during that time nothing is
more important to us than the safety of
our visitors
we want to reiterate our deepest
sympathies to the family and all those
impacted by this tragedy and we will
provide further updates
when we can now since the incident the
park has remained closed initially the
liquid ledger said this was out of
respect for cairo's family but they've
actually now been prevented from
reopening by the local authority the
royal borough of windsor and maidenhead
due to self health and safety grounds
they say have told the company they must
show that they have reduced the risk of
drowning before business can resume here
the thames valley police have said that
kyra's death is not being treated as
suspicious but as unexplained
and the local authority has now
started an investigation and a coroner's
inquest into her death will begin in
g-course